i know you lost your mother recently and
with isolation right now
i don't even think this right question
to ask is how are you but more
how are you coping well i've been
holding up pretty good i've totally
enjoyed quarantine
i was in oklahoma for uh two months i
just got back
matter of fact we had i had gone back
to um go back and prepare for mama's
funeral she passed away march the 14th
so i went back the 15th
and uh when we went back to the funeral
home to say
um okay we're going to pick out the
vault and the casket
and then plan the funeral um
the funeral director andy brown said you
know what i don't think anybody's going
to be able to come in from out of state
because this
coronavirus thing is happening so we had
to kind of postpone everything so i
stayed there
for two months in oklahoma with my
family on the ranch where i grew up
it was very healing it was it was the
greatest
you know just to wake up in the morning
there at susie's house and walk out on
the front porch and see all the baby
calves
and running around and just the spring
happening it was wonderful very healing
now 23 years ago you released a song
what if but
recently you re-released a video
why now when we released what if the
first time
in 97 it was basically for the salvation
army and we performed it at the cowboys
game
in dallas texas on thanksgiving at
halftime
and all the proceeds went to salvation
army
raising awareness for them um and now
it's more prevalent i'd say what if we
just joined together and
sang with one voice reached out with
just one hand maybe we could change
things
and in the video we put things that are
going on now
people wearing the face mask and having
to talk through glasses
and the windows to loved ones
and it's it just it really hit home
that's today more than ever we need to
join together
how are you staying positive in days
like this
for me it's very easy to stay positive
it's
it's hard to think negative when you're
in a world where people
are learning how to do things
differently adjusting
and thinking about others instead of
just yourself
of my actions will affect others
one way or the other so think positive
stay positive and you'll help other
people to be positive
now recently you teamed up with your
ariba co-star melissa peterman
to create a video talking about your
characters on how they are coping with
isolation how did the concept come up
and will you be doing more well it was a
lot of fun she sent it to me and i was
in my
sister susie's uh kitchen and i got in
her pantry
and then when i came out she came
walking through she said
what are you doing and i said oh i guess
i should have warned you about that i
was doing a little video spoof with
melissa peterman and she just died
laughing
so it's a lot of fun melissa comes up
with the greatest ideas
and oh heck yeah i'm good heartbeat in a
heartbeat with
anything with melissa she's always very
creative and a lot of fun and you were
also featured on thomas reds and you
sung be a light with
keith urban hillary scott what does it
mean for you to be part of the project
unfortunately we weren't all together
when we recorded dan huff the producer
and i were
we were in dan's studio there at his
house and
i was recording my part so i saw thomas
shrek not too long after that got to hug
his neck and say thanks for letting me
be a part of it he is a sweetheart
you